i picked a new gun oh what are we gonna
do when we need to head shot big guys
well i got the sniper still i just mean
instead of i had the machine pistol that
round i don't like the machine pistol it
kind of sucks oh yeah no
i just use the revolver i think it's
pretty good i like the revolver pistol
combo that felt nice yeah
this is gtfo and this is a rundown level
c1
something about a cube
cortex
i'm not touching the next one
you do it whoa
at the same time
where are we going oh
oh god
anybody else is getting frozen yeah it's
okay yeah is this how it's supposed to
be yeah oh yeah is this like
whoa green down here
nice nice nice
[Music]
this game is so cool it is equipped some
artifacts i've not equipped any artifact
oh yeah i meant to it didn't oh they
don't seem to change that much
yeah all right what are we looking at oh
there's guys right here oh yeah wait
yeah we are full this room is
immediately full of dudes but they're
spaced out pretty good so we should be
fine
two on the right over there we're not
gonna let them sleep i'm gonna let them
die
you're gonna let them sleep
stab them while they sleep oh please be
safe i don't want to be the guy that
[ __ ] it up
you're probably fine clear clear clear
seems clear clear three one
terminal
yeah what are we looking for did the
cube in zone one find out the data cube
147.
i guess it's through this way
got two dudes three dudes four dudes i
like how green and and and biological
this area is yeah watch out stop stop at
ya
looking not walking and you're like i'll
just keep walking
well to be fair i was on the other side
of that truck from it so i didn't know
there's anything right there i think
this guy right here
uh you're okay yeah you're okay
oh i think there's one around this
corner i see you
hey guys guys
you want to jump down and stab one oh i
would love to jump down from here but i
value my life no do it if you scream
you're safe you want to get the you want
to get the right one
oh my god holy [ __ ]
does it scream the pain away i'm not
more of a screamer i'm kind of like a
you know grunter a grunter it's a grunt
but it's kind of like a grunt like you
stepped on some play-doh you weren't
expecting to have on the ground like a
curious disgusted
like tim the tool man taylor yeah yeah
uh found the door we need to go through
one four seconds great job martin great
job
really helpful this is a class 4 cluster
alarm oh good that sounds cool they can
only
come from
somewhere literally everywhere
yeah
cool cool cool cool is there an up we
can uh we gotta do this oh guys look at
this one you can do this up here oh
that looks safe
this looks like a great spot as long as
there aren't a bunch of them shooting
those white things at us is there any
cover no no no oh what can you hide
behind this hang on i might be able to
get inside of this hang on i'm working
on it all right you do that
that i'm working am i safe oh i'm in
cover am i safe here i think so yeah
with your plan of going out there is the
alarms we'll have to the security we
don't need everyone to do that it's
partial progress now sometimes
i'll hide up there and stay alive just
put down turrets okay okay my bit my
biggest concern is this door right here
but
i'll see foam it there's another door
there
there's like
there's a big opening that door could be
bad yeah that door is a that's anywhere
from we should just do it all right you
know what i like that yeah that's the
attitude i like it yeah
are we winning
you know so far yeah
they're coming from the door we didn't
cover it all no no there's no
that opens up straight to like another
path
and they're going from where we came in
yeah they're coming here they come
that's there's going to be a lot of them
oh there's way more than
oh no nevermind
oh wait
why oh man i forgot to set it to don't
[ __ ] us
oh yeah
oh god trying to attack again oh boy
here we go oh
he's still alive what the [ __ ]
okay
way down here hold that weight down here
in hell we got more coming more coming
here they come
oh these are true
though
oh
lobster and hello
yeah that's not fun circles
can you scan us
trying to get these scans oh security
dot security dots
oh god oh wait you're in hell right now
the love of god wade
you're blocking the entire lane to fire
down
uh well i there was a thing to stand on
there i'm sorry
i didn't choose the holes you were you
were moving you were moving back and
forth
guys
oh god be careful their door is full
i just wanted mom and dad to stop
fighting oh no i like it when we fight
because the makeup sexist oh that is a
lot yeah yeah this room is like packed
how the [ __ ]
yeah how the [ __ ] where do i shoot my
sniper rifle
oh there's like dark area on the left
there's two there are well with the
flashlight why
you're fine it times them up it it gets
them all
synced uh-huh
they do definitely do wait we can get
the two here on our left you can get
that one the right and i think then
we're safe
uh yeah maybe i think we yeah this
cluster here we definitely i think can
get on
so long as that one on the far side over
there is gone okay we're clear to go now
okay three
two one
okay we're clear good good good okay
there's one way to be careful there's
there might be one behind you there's
one there there's one in the stairs at
least here oh there's one to your left
there's one to your left i'll get the
one at the pillar and you get the one on
the right okay charging one over here
the one i'm on charging yeah
go for it three two one
good there's one at the top of those
stairs there's two down the way in that
pit okay i'm in position position yep
three two
one
and clear
there's a five-use med pack up here i
can't hold whoa oh hell yeah
okay oh there's refills and ammo pack
here
it seems like they're stocking us up i
never trust when there's too many how
much [ __ ] there is over here too okay
this is the way to 147. that's
it's a class error alarm oh deactivate
alarm on terminal 174
what i have term this is terminal 915.
okay
what can we ping terminal one seven four
to find out uh yeah actually yeah yes
thermal 174 is in zone one four six ping
out of range 147 144a right now oh
interesting 146 is beyond this door it's
through the door that it says there's a
class error alarm i'm guessing we open
it and run through to the terminal
inside this zone
no it's actually in the next zone after
this zone oh [ __ ]
are we all here i think so yeah we i
guess do it doesn't really matter i'm
doing it
i don't know what the hell this means
basically keep moving forward
that's big that's big that sounds big
don't look back don't look back don't
look back okay we just gotta go i don't
see anything on the other side
nothing nothing
clear clear where's the door okay the
terminal find the terminal no it's in
the next room
we gotta go to 146. there's 147b there's
there's a few things in here
wait they're not aggravated
yeah i know
oh but they are from behind us
on our backs yeah
i found the cover of the ladder right
now
careful oh [ __ ] wait
i didn't have it
oh yes you did
what do you mean you didn't think
they're just pissed i don't know i i'm
telling you they're just getting pissed
randomly you walked up to it what do you
mean
just [ __ ] them up yeah okay oh lord oh
god 146 is through here oh my god
what do we do
oh my god what do i do my turn down
back away from the door door's turning
nope nevermind we good we good moving in
there's there's like five
more one of them came to get me behind
you is anyone here helping me
yep
thank you how much you died
oh my god bum bum has a bunch yeah i
sure do i sure do i got you about i got
here
okay we gotta go they're just gonna keep
spawning
uh this door right here
are we in zone 146 yet
no i have to hack this door
jacket baby
oh
that's a good sound right
a yellow key card
is happening
all right
that was a lock burner that was so worth
it all right we got a yellow key card uh
let me see nothing in this room uh
terminal somewhere
this is 145 g oh my god
coming from behind
we got big spinner big spit lady oh [ __ ]
okay yeah yeah come on can you play
hang on i gotta run first one second
whoa oh my god nope not today
doors open okay progressing there's guys
in here there are dudes
left side a couple
this is it 146. okay we need to keep
yellow what what i got where's the door
it has that way does it wait right here
right here pinging
pink come on no moving targets i see
them
security stick once it started
yep circle circle circle
i'm gonna turn it i'm gonna turn it good
call
wait can you crouch you're gonna be in
the front of everybody thank you yep
give another ping mark
yep all right we're good
i see nothing okay on the other side
of the current
terminal terminal
[Music]
no enemies what where is it
found it found it what do i do what do i
do uh deactivate alarm
on terminal 174 i don't know
yeah look for something that says like
alarm type deactivate alarm
[Music]
commands
oh god i got it deactivate
alarms
executing alarm shutdown protocol
connecting active alarm returning valid
terminal id
shutting down alarms
[Music]
oh okay it sounds like one more wave
might be coming
uh-huh i'm gonna turn it i'm gonna turn
it uh from the other side big lady
oh big lady draw let her come to the
doorway let me hit yeah yeah good goal
good
trying to call
oh there she is
got her nice shot nice shot oh yeah
okay
that's why they got that stressful yeah
a little refill pack here
yeah we passed by so many boxes i'm
gonna backtrack and scout through yeah
honestly we're not in that bad of shape
yeah surprisingly
no
i'm low on ammo yeah yeah the med pack
we could everyone actually yeah
yeah i got i'll come back and do that
and then i'll uh
i'll come grab everybody here you need
health definitely uh you get ammo uh bob
you need help i'm okay well okay i mean
i'm gonna use this i'm sure there's more
we've run through like five rooms there
are also all those rooms in the main
area where the they broke through the
doors of the start we didn't look
through any of those rooms either ah
let's just let's just go for the
objective yeah i think we're gonna help
you and ammo right now
all right
it's fun
so back towards where you guys are going
we're good yeah i think we're set we
might backtrack out of here anyway and
grab more who knows
oh don't spear me what are you doing
no
i heard it
maybe i don't have a full refill i
thought i had one in the top right does
it say that you have a tool right
one but i mean maybe i'm crazy i guess
i'm crazy no i'm gonna use it okay
well i used one but i thought it was a i
swear to god it was a two-user
just waiting for you guys it's all gooch
it's fine
oh my god this
skin
nothing on the other side of this door
yeah maybe we were supposed to run in
deactivate alarm and then do this i
don't know
whoa oh wait i'm converting the scan
look at that look at over that way
yeah it's cool oh it's neat
like an ecological greenhouse or
something yeah it's cool
i'm sure it was cooler before everything
yeah we're good nothing here nothing
artifact
another artifact right in the middle of
the ground what is that it's a half pipe
yeah oh
that a cute
skateboard
are you picking up a tiny flash drive do
this
oh data cube
oh oh
wait it's kind of
this way
oh god you're going the other way when
we follow speed dice uh maybe we got
incoming
oh geez okay oh [ __ ]
it seems like a pass
fall behind
wait this doesn't just loop around does
it
the objective is just survive we just
gotta last out
oh yeah there's no loops
[Music]
all right we'll stick together then
i'm gonna put a turret down facing like
one of these ways
careful you might lose it in this
dimension
oh that would be funny they always come
back
you say that
oh right above me right away write a
movie
maybe we should stay on each other yeah
oh
no okay
i come back and i'm standing in a corner
yeah locate three data cubes
that's yes that was the initial
objective we got one okay door where
door what door
148. so i guess we do uh
we read that zone is that valuable
oh sure 151 whatever i can ask
oh yeah wait it's it's way back
wow there's a door
597 i see
those noises make my life i'm glad man
i'm glad i am following you where are we
going i don't know how do we get in here
where am i up here i think yeah we
really just ran in a blind panic earlier
and i don't think any of us knew where
the hell we were moving yeah no just
just forward
very fortunate we've made it to the
right place 148 to 154 let's go that is
what we okay don't scare anything
cool it's full it's shockingly it's full
and the door is fine
yeah as long as no one's shooting their
gun or screaming or doing anything like
you know
okay boss would do that no one's to the
left there's one two three four five six
of them here
seven eight yeah one yeah
okay do you think i could get this guy
without the others is there unless
there's one further left close to him
he's probably alone uh
he has no friends
okay
i'm gonna do it
oh
goodnight oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh they're all they're all you're behind
the turret
getting behind the turret oh hey i put
another turret down scanning i'm going
behind white star too haha
i did it i don't know why that's what
i'm saying but
okay
oh what oh [ __ ] okay yeah yeah upstairs
oh i'm gonna pick my turret up before it
starts killing me i'm going for it the
hunt is on
[Laughter]
intimidating and in charge when you make
those noises thank you
all right there's just one on the other
side of the store but i have a sneaking
suspicion that means he's nope
[Laughter]
oh
what are you doing
[Music]
look i was at the point of no return of
uh thrusting right click
literally just right click got me
stressed over here i'm making tyler
right click this i'm not a right clicker
here's uh here's a ammo uh this is not
an alarm door so
we're good on this door
there are things other side
it might be
right on the other side might be below
it looks like there's another level down
there
oh checkpoint
i like that hi
yeah it was a little ooh look all their
friends
[ __ ]
all right there's uh
several in this room but they're all
spaced out you go right i'll go
downstairs
i just want you to know if you see these
dogs in your yard i'm upstairs going on
while you're flying it's down below you
i'm gonna get it
bing-bong i'm gonna get it okay you get
that one uh we might need a third here
coming in you guys go for it
hit him okay
three two one
okay why they sounded pretty lined up
how did i get there first
we were counting spears got a range my
damage is on your hands mark all right
well maybe you shouldn't i just be
opening doors
one at the top of those stairs over
there it seems um three clusters
yeah how far do our flashlights go uh
is that working yeah yeah thanks
okay
you can see him periodically look at
that tush
look at it mush
hey i got another artifact and there's
some glowy's over here nice wait what do
you mean the glowys
you know some chloe's bro some glows you
ever uh park up on make out ridge and
climb in the back seat get a little
glowy uh i'm european
i'm sorry we don't have a makeout you
ever walk down to make out square and
sit at your favorite cafe and get a
little blowy i mean glowy yeah i said
the said the quiet part loud my bad
how many of them are in here mark just
three
seasons four just four actually but
let's go forward oh man we really
really gotta get all that info i think
the one close to us i think there's a
bubble there's five yeah there's five
ones above you okay yeah i can get these
two i think three two one
wham
wham oh come on die
die die there we go
wait don't help him or anything
there's two over to the right way do you
see him
i see one on the other side of this
pillar here there's one further to the
right ah you see that one uh there were
six in here oh there's the other one
huge seven there's ten maybe twelve
oh jesus
it's not it's not an auction mark
you're supposed to count them all at the
same time
oh they're oh no they're there yeah
they're there they're they're being here
they're they you have the scanner you
are there they're they're there what i
do know
so we do these three all at the same
time i think so i'm gonna just get a
little farther back for this guy are
there four heroes yeah there's four
let's go for it
okay charging
jesus
charging again
get him get him yeah
go up top
you can also if you have just like one
or two you could also right click spam
them and just stagger them from doing
anything until someone helps you that's
true oh yeah that's what that's for yeah
that's why that exists
[Music]
i don't want to brag or anything but i
killed like three guys in this area whoa
this is a classic five alarm
well there's high ground in here so
that's something yeah this is impossible
to block off yeah i think what i think
we should run around and do the circles
and then i'll put my turret like here on
the stairs and we can go on top of the
stairs and uh do you want to use your
shitty
well i mean they're also going to come
through that ladder down at the other
side pretty good might as well just
point your turret at that probably uh
like down here yeah they're gonna come
through there okay well so maybe i'll
put it at the bottom and just point it
out this way yeah why not
sure sure
don't mind
sure
sure thing
i wasn't getting
i feel like every time i do a door even
if we say it wade's like oh god jesus
[ __ ]
why did you warn me
why are we playing this game
i don't see them oh yes i do
oh i turned out on my left
let's go up the stairs if we can
no no no no no we got this
oh
okay
well
there's a big up top what is that what
is that what is that circle okay we
don't always get to pick our circle
place wade yeah man
he's gonna deal with the hand you're
built
are they the other side of that wall
yeah where'd they go you're already done
go upstairs upstairs if you well we
don't even really need to but
go upstairs it's trouble oh it's cool i
think we might need to
there's a lot of them oh they climb the
ladder they climb the ladder whoever's
upstairs with me they climb the ladder
okay whoa whoa
a guy naruto did up the
theirs
oh i got this i got this letter i got
this letter
what die why won't you die
help on the ladder please helping oh god
please helping on the ladders got you
got you
we're still clear we're clear we're
clear
yeah wow you took a lot of damage you're
good well thank god i have we've had the
other door covered
god damn it every time
excellent
excellent work hey
whatever i tried to turn it will never
be attacked light
what do you it's yours
i was like we're good i'm going to take
a quick sip of drink inside i blast him
yeah blast him nah he's cool
wait stop sprinting or he's uncool we're
safe in this room he's do i blast him or
not blast last time we lost him
oh wait no oh god oh god oh
god
oh my god that was a bad call i'm gonna
admit it i'm i'm man enough to admit it
a bad call
oh this is a big guy
whoa
another big all right i'm gonna waste
some more sniper ammo
four big dudes how many bigs are there
here it's all bigs
you didn't just underestimate you killed
them
even
mark what do you mean it's not like it
says what it is it's a white dot there
were like six white dots i assumed they
would all be small
that would have been a safe bet about it
that's a fair assumption oh
i'm throwing a glow stick
nice work
all right
i'm happy to say there's one more
ah great
you handled that i'm gonna get my sweet
chicken out take some of this
they're one of these
all right well now i'm very much out of
ammo all right me too i am out of ammo
well thankfully guys i have one ammo
pack use who wants it
uh
zero zero no i'm good we have a winner
okay
i'm good i'm good probably i got i got
sniper so we i got the important one i
don't need my secondary i have three
lock melters uh give it to someone else
oh your little one here bob so you get
it merry christmas yay
were you coming back to get it mark no
no i just was checking the room
more being so funny about that
okay you got that sniper ammo did you
give it to bob
yeah
he's got it bob was a good church
i'm just surprised he didn't say
anything i saw you turn back around and
i was like man he didn't even he's not
even mad or anything he just gave him
right up on that one stop stop moving oh
geez no oh god
[Applause]
deploying glow stick oh sorry guys
guys there's a high ground on the
opposite side if we need to retreat
i need to retreat
i am almost out of ammo
happy to inform retreat was already in
progress what do i shoot don't worry
he's got the snipers
yeah you're right i do i have a lot of
extra sniper ammo to use on this he's
such a good shot oh they came around the
back way this is interesting
can i stagger them with my uh right
click yeah yeah yeah
it did nothing
just funked on his ass
all right
there's a where's that other red dot
where's the other red dot what is that
it's uh it's whatever at this point it
could be anything
okay here hold on there's two chests
here this could be ammo
no it's not
oh it's seafoam grenades at least yeah
that's got ourselves we're safe
glow stick well i'm going to go ahead
and use those tools how's your turret
guys how do you feel about a security
door i'm ready good morning that's okay
there's no alarm
oh you tricked me all right
i'm gonna heal you
no i don't why are you eating right now
what's wrong with me my food's here i
don't know what do you want me to do
about it chicken
this was scheduled for a time eat before
or after the food was real quick
i'm blabber-dasted it's what i okay
we're doing it hang on wait i had i
found an ammo pack i'm gonna
where's bob
maybe use it on yourself no
i gave me one no no i gave it to me one
bullet left that sniper is that any
bullets no the sniper is what it needs
we need that
how do you feel about two tentacles two
tentacles there was two okay good about
that i found one okay we have the sniper
ammo now is there other stuff there
might be three tentacles okay okay cool
cool
[Music]
oh
my god
how did that not come up on the scan
what am i i said
it was it is
it was not for four there's four
okay all right good snipey man
he's gonna get the sniper
[Applause]
five there's one far do you see the far
middle oh what is god
god okay that guy over there is going to
move soon yeah yeah your time
i like dodged in real life to get away
from his tentacles
how close are those tentacles uh you're
clear you're clear
all right got another one
he heard that he heard that
oh no snipers are loud
oh you get behind this door get behind
the door get behind the door oh you're
right good good call
wait oh they're coming from behind oh
behind us oh god
that is that is a terrible sound that
was yeah that was rumbly can you uh can
you make any scans trying
got anything going on there's the one
for you thanks you're welcome
i already i have one bullet
go turret go
oh i do have a seat from griffin here
they come
turret no
wait careful guys behind get behind the
turret get behind the turret what turn
oh you're right into pokey pokey
i am so [ __ ]
oh they're here that's a lot i'm down
down i'm down oh god oh god i'm running
for it
but there's still
off into the darkness
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh was that hell there was no how would
we ever have enough ammo for all of that
all those big dudes
what would we do all right well that was
serendipitous because i actually have to
go and take a call what right but we
scheduled this right now
to die right here yeah good yeah it
works for me
[Music]